welcome back to your peers organizer
Pearl Davis has racked up a legion of
online followers and plenty of
breathless newspaper coverage by sharing
her it send reviews on modern feminism
the New York Post called her the female
Andrew Tate so she tapped into genuine
female pushed back to the excesses of
wokory or is she just an attention
seeker we'll find out a moment but first
let's take a look at the clip of Senator
viral
a lot of people think I'm insane because
I don't think women should vote
everybody thinks I'm crazy for this
opinion if anything this is probably my
most extreme opinion ninety percent of
women have been on birth control one out
of three women has had one out of three
women has an STD uh average body count
is over five so that your average wife
has slept with over five people 95
percent of women are not virgins on
their wedding days so I understand the
complaint
alongside political journalist Ava 17 it
was nodding furiously along there to
everything she heard right Paul you've
become it would be called the female
Andrew Tate how do you plead
well I take it as a compliment you know
I'm a fan of Andrew Tate of everything
he says
um it depends what we're talking about
but overall I think he's got a good
message I think he's good for young men
okay look you're talking about women
predominantly
um which is why you've got this big
following and your view is that modern
feminism is deeply flawed I would argue
a lot of your proposals like taking the
vote away from are deeply regressive why
would you want to remove just from
yourself the right to vote well um what
happened was I I had the same view right
um back when I started I was like why
I found out that only five percent of
women wanted the right to vote and I
couldn't figure out like why would women
not no it's true
at the time it is they've been
conditioned by men to think that they
shouldn't have of that I mean that's
what they say but you know I started
reading their writings right and what I
found out was that the reason a lot of
women advocated for it was because they
believed it was the beginning of the
breakdown of the family you know before
you became one in marriage 85 percent of
people were married and you know I I
hate to say it but they were right what
has happened 100 years later what's like
what to do with them having the vote
well it also goes back to responsibility
um
again men are 80 to 90 percent of the
military they run all of the
infrastructures that make Society run
so I just think if we want an equal say
in society then be equal do 50 of the
hard jobs be 50 of the military in the
U.S um they're fine 250 000 if they are
not they don't join uh Selective Service
which is essentially the truth okay but
on specifically on the vote what would
having the right to vote have to do with
family cohesion for example well because
again before you weren't trying to
divide a family it was one family unit
you had one vote for the family I mean I
I don't think it's good for a family to
have two votes Ava your mouth seems to
have dropped right now I know it's a
sort of a galaxy brain I feel like you
know the stat state of putting down are
perhaps correct in some years they just
kind of don't really add up I mean just
just to take you back to the to the
women's writings that you've allegedly
read I mean absolutely
at the time that you're talking about
you know women weren't really allowed to
write they weren't allowed to go to
school
that's incorrect the first female
property the first female property owner
was in the 1600s the idea that women
couldn't work I'm so excited no the
first no no the first female the first
female millionaire was in the uh late
1800s so no it wasn't it was self-made
yes yes
what what law permitted that well there
was no law I mean there's always been
women
let's get on to the vote so what I don't
understand is you know a part of your
message I've just you know I've
researched you today and hang on a
minute okay you know your big push is
that you care about men and you don't
think that men are getting enough of a
say hang on I haven't made the point yet
um because of feminism okay what I
wonder is when you start making calls
out like repeal the 19th women shouldn't
be allowed to vote how is that helping
young men because these young men have
women in their lives they have mothers
they have sisters they have teachers and
they turn around they don't know how to
act around women because you're giving
them license to be misogynistic I
wouldn't call it misogynistic I say be
equal so again men do all of them well
then okay I'd love for the feminists
please apply for the oil rigs please go
do the hard jobs in society they're open
they're hiring because I don't equate
for I I don't think men or women are
equal until we do the equal work so no
no listen listen go go apply to beyond
the oil rigs go do go be a plumber go be
electrician go be on the front lines of
the military and then we should have
equal rights but until feminists are
willing to do that I don't believe we
should have the freedom without the
response okay well I don't think that
I'm physically built for that you might
be but I'm absolutely no no
oh wow you said you were a volleyball
player and so you've got more strength
than I do I don't think I don't have
more strength
I don't have more strength than the
average man but my again it goes back to
go be a plumber you want to be equal go
beat also but you don't want you want
divorce to be made illegal yes why yes
because I don't think what we have today
is really marriage What is marriage it's
For Better or For Worse for richer for
poorer in sickness and in health till
death do us part that's what marriage is
supposed to be but feminists have ruined
marriage for the people that actually
believe in marriage when there is a 50
divorce rate and the average man why is
that all done to the women though I I
didn't say that it was all down to the
women
you asked why I want divorce to be
banned can I finish yeah first so I'm
saying you know the people that believe
in divorce go be in long-term
relationships leave marriage for the
people that actually believe in For
Better or For Worse for richer for poor
in sickness and in health till death do
us part doesn't the sanctity of marriage
also rely on the woman being a virgin so
you wouldn't be able to get married I'm
what do you what do you mean well you've
spoken quite openly about how you're not
a virgin and so if you want to preserve
that sanctity of marriage
upholding standards that you don't know
you know and that's a fair that's a fair
complaint I wish I was but you know we
can't go back I don't know what you want
me to say I just don't think yeah that
you get to be here and you get to be
paid for your views and you're telling
other women that they shouldn't be
allowed
okay if I may at some stage jump in
um isn't the whole point of being a
feminist though that women are entitled
to have their own views absolutely so
she's perfectly entitled to her views
yeah but you can't you might not like
that but I'm here isn't she exercising
her right as a are you a feminist no I
am not really no you know I wouldn't
have done good at that time you don't
want to be a feminist no because I if
feminists really believed in equality
but you guys don't I would love for you
there is an oil rig hiring there is an
engineer I would actually love to see
Avis no seriously seriously uh there is
a building being built next to my
building go do it feminists
when you find the man you want to get
married to are you saying you will
literally you will be with that man
whatever happens the rest of your life
yes for for the vows that we're supposed
to live how do you know you can keep
them I I mean look it I think it's a
choice and that's the thing like women
are so willing to leave marriages
because they're not happy this is not
about happiness the most important thing
is the children and the problem is we
have a modern society where it's me me
me my feelings leave when I feel like it
instead of doing what's best for the
kids hey but a good old say
it's a little about listening to
actually take where some of it I really
don't agree with I don't agree with the
vote stuff when I have things like that
I think there'll be a lot of people
especially older generation women
perhaps who think you know what she's
got a point well I mean I believe in
agency so I think that if a woman is
going to look after her children of
intervals that's absolutely fine I also
believe in your right to speak your mind
about it what I don't understand
before in the 1920s women could speak
openly at this idea that like women
couldn't talk the last 500 years there
have been women throughout the American
States
has been there have been women
throughout history that have read
written and been very influential in
society okay so this idea like women
could never do it well I don't
understand though is when it gets
spiteful okay because you put down a few
arguments that I think are perfectly
like you know they're kind of
Evangelical in their Christian but those
are your right to say what I don't
understand is when it kind of seeps into
this sort of you call women fat you say
that they shouldn't have other questions
you know I mean the question is are they
fat yes or no the average American woman
is 170 pound that's pounds that's
objectively overwhelmed I mean let's be
honest we now celebrate morbid obesity
as some kind of body positively and it
is complete nonsense so actually on that
point again there's a bit of Truth and
this is the problem this is the problem
how have we come to celebrate morbid
obesity is body positive nonsense we're
not talking about Mobility so I was
actually watching your podcast earlier
and you you spoke to someone who was I
would say probably a size 12 and you
called her it fat a beast and a divorce
say she was fat obese I mean like I
don't know what to say this is the thing
women we don't want to live in reality
we don't want to say things that are
true was she fat yes was she a divorce
say yes these things are just objective
facts okay I'm gonna have to objectively
she insulted me first they always I'm
gonna have to objectively end the debate
but it was an interesting conversation I
think we should get YouTube Back
Together As a matter of urgency uh thank
you very much Paul thank you over